it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get to visit Tamriel
on console because the Elder Scrolls is
making its way to ps4 and xbox one play
as a dragon knight Templar sorcerer or
nyteblayde and enjoy the nonlinear
gameplay whether it be the quests from
aggressive peasants random events with
strangers or free roaming the open world
with friends there's no mode for
single-player offline but there is
content for players who wish to play
solo but then you got to ask yourself
why am i playing an MMO pick your
faction on the 9th also this week
Adventures of pip makes a successful
leap from Kickstarter to steam to Wii U
this week to prove that you're worth
your weight in pixels pip can absorb
pixels and change into different forms
so you'll have lots of new gameplay
elements to keep it interesting it might
feel like your standard retro platformer
but there's a lot more going on behind
the scenes to create a truly unique and
enjoyable game if you're not a wee
person you can pick it up on Steam but
if you do own a wii-u you can start your
adventure on the 11th on a darker note
PC gamers can pick up ko lot on Steam
this week which is based on the Dyatlov
pass incident in 1959 nine hikers tore
through their tents and fled a campsite
some of them barefoot under heavy
snowfall no one really knows what
happened on that fateful trip that
claimed the lives of nine Russian hikers
this game is meant to shed some light on
what really happened enjoy discover the
truth on the 9th doctor mario is back to
cure what ails you with miracle cure on
the 3ds if you've never played a dr
mario game before it's like Tetris but
with matching colors the miracle cure is
a bonus for when a meter fills up and it
gives you a huge help like erasing an
entire row but if you're not into
vaccinations you can just turn that off
and roll the dice good luck get your
prescription on the 11th finally this
week drastic world gets a Lego videogame
accompaniment that follows all the
different storylines from all the
different Jurassic park's yes
even that one the game will feature 20
levels with five of them based on each
film and it also features original audio
from those films complete with dr. Ian
Malcolm laying down some hot logic along
the way now eventually dif i have
dinosaurs on your on your dinosaur right
the player will have a choice of more
than 100 playable characters including
more than 20 dinosaur species and also
the schoolhouse rock Jurassic Park mr.
DNA start taming Raptors on the 12 for
further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week